giants right-handed starter facing the
dodgers
for the first time this year mike kruco
it's johnny cueto johnny coito 35 years
old his 14th year at the big league
level has taken the ball for the 17th
time this year
cradle got him swinging with the high
fastball
got him to chase amazing david price
makes his seventh start
got a 284 era and it starts this season
that is
the third walk of the inning the bases
are loaded
and welcome back brandon crawford now
the one strike offering
swinging the ground ball right past
third it's a fair ball
headed down to left field live flores
scores
yustrimski right behind him he scores
solano to third
and it's a stand-up double for brandon
crawford
who delivers in his first at-bat off the
injured list
not a classic swing it was kind of an
awkward looking swing
but he pounded that one down
and right along the third base line and
i think significantly he just went with
it
this had to be i guess 02 a big chopper
he's a hustler and he will beat it out
helmet comes flying off never boring
johnny cueto
well think about johnny cueto i mean he
is such a hard worker
between starts that you don't worry
about him running
and pulling anything because he does an
enormous amount of leg work
i think wilmer you like this matchup
against david price flores walked and
scored one of those two giants runs in
the first inning
oh two into the gap in right center
field ballinger chasing he's not gonna
get to it
and now slater will motor his way to
third he's gonna come home
and austin slater will score without a
play it's a double
wilmer flores makes it three nothing
giants that's the thing when you open up
the right side of an
infield that can have a lot of effect
how you hit the ball to the outfield
31 pitches through the first three
innings of the game he's allowed two
hits
two singles muncie
hits a pop-up foul coming well back
and into the second deck and a fan hit a
bare-headed catch in the first row of
the second deck
and he came up ready to throw foul
and out of play all right let's take a
look at that fan catch you're talking
about
had him played perfectly
and he he posed afterward o2 pitch
struck him out swinging wow
two and two the count
he's struck him out 94 mile an hour heat
on the outside
three up and three down they lead three
nothing this is the bottom part of the
order here
price throws and a swing and a chopper
slowly hit to short taylor
charges and he went to scoop it up and
couldn't field it cleanly
and i don't know if he was gonna get
tyro estrada anyway taylor who does not
have the classic shortstops arm he's
he's a he's a good player and is being
asked to play
shortstop they're going to charge him
with an error huh
so taylor gets charged with an error
which i mean it looked like an error
when you watched it
so here is slater now to try and deliver
a run for the giants with a clutch hit
center field it's falling it's in there
here comes estrada
and bellinger will not challenge him
another two out rbi hit austin slater
has delivered
four-nothing giants and that's how you
take advantage of an error
2-2 pitch pujol strikes out swinging
fastball got him at 94.
fifth johnny cueto strikeout
fifth strikeout for johnny cueto again
perfect location with the fastball boy
he has
absolutely been dot the corners with
both types of movement
four seam two seam i mean he's just
putting on a clinic with his fastball
command today
still even at age 41 not easy to do
now rough over to second crawford back
to first cuello covering
double play
right center field that gets down into
the gap
and it rolls all the way out to the 415
side
ruff heading around second digging for
third
stand up triple for darren ruff
the second day as a 35 year old
take a look at the little flat breaking
ball that bickford gives him and
darren ruff takes advantage of it but
again
going the opposite gap taking advantage
of the outside location
he's setting up for outside this time he
gets a break a ball rifles it through
and right now he realizes hey
i got a chance for a three bagger stand
up style
now crawford's going to be intentionally
walked by the way and you hear giants
fans reaction to that
and now they've walked lamont way junior
as well
so consecutive automatic walks
and bigfoot maybe vikrant maybe answers
now does that count against my record
on the fourth pitch throws the fastball
and strikes him out
loaded him up intentionally with
back-to-back intentional walks and the
giants
never did score they had a runner at
third with one out and base is loaded
with two down the dodgers keep it a four
run game
giants with a four nothing lead but the
base is loaded for the dodgers as the
giants make a pitching change
harleen garcia the new pitcher now for
gabe kepler so here is bellinger
struck him out
the heater down and away at 94.
and he leaves them loaded
[Applause]
it's been a big weapon of his this year
and he's had a good campaign
oh two sliders struck him out swinging
he's got it going it's a late break and
it's a big break
got him swinging 96 miles an hour
and a great inning for dominic leone
so here is lamont wade jr it's one way
to left center field he's got a hit
against a lefty
and it's going to go to the wall solano
around third here comes donovan solano
the throw
is high and lamont wade jr
on the board five nothing giants
and that's a hit against a left-handed
pitcher first one he's ever had as a big
leaguer
i guarantee you that feels good
well he does it in a money situation
needs to throw a strike
he does and he struck him out with the
slider and if i could wear
white wristbands and white sleeves i
would
slider struck him out looking back door
frisbee
i love that 2-2 got him swinging
and tyler rogers strikes out the side
one and two bellinger on the ground to
first
darren ruff's got it and the giants beat
the dodgers
five nothing the final score